Ah, Halloween! Cette fête typiquement française
Alors, Halloween, moi je trouve...
qu'est ce qu'il y a la chose?
Ah oui! On vient de passer la barre des 11 millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne Youtube, donc déjà, merci à tous
Alors, Halloween - moi j'adore. Chaque année c'est vraiment l'occasion de se faire gentiment peur entre potes.
On se déguise avec des petits costumes des familles. Voilà, c'est le folklore
Tout le monde fête Halloween, mais on sait pas trop d'où elle vient, cette fête
Alors en fait, Halloween est une fête païenne
traditionnelle originaire des îles anglo-celtes... Ouais,trop long, chiant, chiant, hyper chiant!
Oh puis merde, c'est juste une excuse pour se bourrer la gueule
Pour faire court, Halloween c'est une fête d'origine celte qui s'est introduite en Amérique du Nord après une vague d'immigration d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote...
Ok..
tout va bien
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote à l'époque on sculptait pas des citrouilles mais des bons gros navets
comme dans le comte irlandais jack à la lanterne, et puis les américains ont remplacé les navets par des citrouilles parce que
parce que c'était de la merde en fait. Alors moi quand j'étais petit il n'y avait pas Halloween en France ça n'existait pas
la France opposait totalement à cette fête. Non à Halloween! Ce ne sont pas nos valeurs! Et puis finalement un jour là la magie a opéré
vous savez qu' Halloween peuvent apporter plusieurs millions de dollars par an
ce sont nos valeurs
qui veux des citrouilles? Alors j'ai appris selon wikipedia qu'on peut aussi dire L'Halloween et qui dit ça en fait moi je fête L'Halloween
tout comme la pâques et la noël avec ma femme hein la Corinne
et maintenant quelques astuces pour une soirée de l'halloween de qualité. Sculptez une citrouille en suivant un tuto sur youtube
une fois terminé, il vous reste plus qu'à la jeter et à en acheter une déjà toute faite. Accrochez à votre maison cette fameuse toile d'araignée
de merde qui va rester toute l'année. Réunissez tout vos bonbons dégueulasses ou périmés pour les redistribuer
Décorez votre maison avec des trucs bien flippants et badants cette année comme décoration effrayante. Cette année j'ai accroché une photo de mon ex
avec son nouveau mec
bordel qu'est ce qu'ils s'aiment et mon avis d'imposition en fait
ça me fait toujours un petit quelque chose
Accueillez vos invités à votre soirée déguisée et comme tous les ans sans surprise on aura:
le costume hyper original bah quoi tu me reconnais pas
je suis Harley queen
Yes...
Le mec pas déguisé et qui fait toujours la même blague: je suis déguisé en mec pas déguisé
celui ou celle qui n'a pas trop compris le concept de faire peur
Happy halloween
Je suis là je suis terrorisée le mec qui a voulu faire une référence
trop poussé en fait je suis habille en résistant normand de la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale enfin début 45 une période riche en
péripéties. Celui qui est pas très doué en travaux manuels
Tu connais pas
le costume qu'on a du mal à comprendre en fait un mélange de deux clowns magnum est un épouvantail de hawaï
Oh puis au final chacun son style
Bonjour jean séry témoins de jéhovah je suis là pour répandre la parole du christ et du seigneur
ah ouais le costume hyper original bien ouej dont je suis sérieux c'est vraiment là pour
insane il y a des bieres dans le frigo tu te mets à l'aise
Racontez vous des petites histoires effrayantes.Et donc la toto dit bah c'était pas une saucisse c'était ma teub
Mec ça fait pas peur
Ouais c'était pas une saucisse c’était ma teub
Regardez un film d'horreur à plusieurs avec plein de bons screamers ouais les screamers, vous savez pas ce que c'est?
Montez un peu le son allez-y  monter le son bah c'est ça
Yes, désolé c'est le concept d'ailleurs ça marche uniquement parce qu'il y a un son bien flippant. Avec un autre son ça fait pas le même effet
quoique en fait l'image aussi doit être flippante, parce que si on met pas la bonne bah c'est nul
Attend mais ça deviens n'importe quoi ce screamer là
Et puis pour finir,
bourrez vous bien avec gueule ho j'adore halloween putain. Les enfants vous voulez de la coke ou quoi?
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
- Oui? - Des bonbons ou un sort. - bah désolé je tourne des vidéos en fait là je suis occupé
- DES BONBONS OU UN SORT!
Pas mal l'effet en tout cas je,  je suis occupé j'ai pas le temps puis en plus j'ai pas de bonbons en fait
Ok
C'était quoi ce délire
Waouh qu'est ce qui se passe là
Attend mec c'est bizarre, mon micro marche plus là
la caméra non plus elle est bloquée sur enregistrer on dirait le début d'un mauvais film d'horreur
Oh non, - quoi? - Oh non si c'est un film d'horreur je suis noir je vais mourir au début?
- non mec
on est plus fort que ça, on est soudé, et on va prouver au reste du monde qu'on est plus puissant que les clichés hollywoodiens
J'entend du bruit dans la salle de bain! J'y vais!
Oh non, non!
Oh putain! Je rêve ou le placard bouge tout seul...
- Mec, sois un bonhomme, ouvre
- Ok
Tu vois c'était qu'un chat mais j'en étais sûr déstresse tout va bien! Norman?, norman?
- Joyeuses fêtes de l'halloween
Sous-titres réalisés par des abonnés de Norman